un contrat de 2,5 milliards d'euros
signé en un temps record finalisé en
moins de quatre mois
cet accord avec la france démontre
l'empressement de la grèce à se
renforcer sur le plan militaire par
rapport à son voisin turc
depuis plusieurs mois ankara multiplie
les actions en méditerranée menaçant la
souveraineté grecque dans la région une
position intenable pour athènes qui a
décidé de réagir fermement
avec l'achat d'avions de chasse rafale
la puissance de feu de l'armée de l'air
et les knicks se multipliera il
contribuera au renforcement de la
capacité de combat et du mécanisme de
dissuasion de l'armée de l'air et des
forces armées dont la mission principale
consiste à défendre l'intégrité
territoriale et les droits souverains
dans notre pays
en outre la décision de se procurer des
chasseurs français rafale souligner le
caractère stratégique des relations
greco française et le soutien
indéfectible de la france à notre pays
contre les défis et les menaces athènes
voulant disposer sans attendre des
appareils douze sont achetés d'occasion
afin de répondre à l'urgence
les avions seront prélevés sur
l'inventaire de l'armée de l'air
française
un échange qui renforce la collaboration
entre la france et la grèce après
plusieurs mois de tensions et de luttes
d'influencé dans la région
paris affirme sa position aux côtés de
son allié européen
la qualité de la coopération entre la
france et la grèce est particulièrement
visible en méditerranée où les exercices
sont multipliés ces derniers mois à la
fois dans un cadre bilatéral et
multilatéral
cet espace qui est au carrefour de
nombreuses crises en libye en syrie et
soumis à des tensions croissantes et
face à tous ces défis il est essentiel
que les européens prennent conscience
que cet ensemble en se dotant de
capacités propres que nous trouverons
des solutions durables
la coopération franco grecque pourrait
même se poursuivre dans le secteur
maritime
athènes doit lancer un appel à
candidatures pour lui fournir quatre
frégates et en rénover quatre autres
navale groupe leader français du secteur
devrait y répondre dans les prochains
jours
selon la ministre des armées florence
parly